the spider-man far from home trailer is
about to play but if you haven't seen
Avengers end game yet stop watching
because there's some serious spoilers
about to come up but if you have seen
Avengers endgame enjoy the trailer
everywhere I go I see his face
listen yeah I miss him too I don't think
Tony would have done what he did if he
didn't know that you were gonna be here
after he was gone
you gonna be a next time right now well
no I don't have time I'm too busy doing
your jobs I'm kidding I'm kidding look
keep up the good work because I am going
on vacation
heads up Nick Fury's calling I don't
really want to talk to me resolve why
because if you don't talk to him and I
have to talk I don't want to talk though
you sent Nick Fury to voicemail I gotta
go you do not dosed Nick Fury that dorks
what's up we're just talking about the
trip
I'm here in st. mark opposed oh I think
MJ really likes me when I first Aloha
you're a very difficult person to
contact spider-man
this is mr. Beck we could have used
someone like you on my world new world
Beck is from Earth just not out a snap
to our home in our dimension we have a
job to do
you're coming with us
it's gotta be something else you can use
what about the offworld captain Holmes
unavailable the coach their friendly
neighborhood spider-man [ __ ] please
you've been to space what do you want
Peter I want to go back on my trip with
the girl who I really like you tell her
how I feel
MJ I am spider-man no of course not I
mean it's kind of obvious you're right
you may not be ready but this is my
responsibility
saving the world requires sacrifice
sometimes people die
[Music]
so I feel like I put my friends in
danger
the world needs the next Iron Man you
going to step up not
[Music]
guys outta here I work with spider-man
you were through Slayer
I won't win spider-man not for
spider-man
[Music]
how's it going everybody it's Warren and
Wow we have to talk about this new
spider-man far from home trailer
obviously if you watch the spider-man
far from home trailer you know that it
includes some serious spoilers for
Avengers end game so if you watch the
trailer and you've seen Avengers and
game I probably don't need to say this
but I will just in case spoilers are
coming this is a marketing move that
nobody has really done before nobody has
really put a major spoiler for an
insanely huge movie in another movie
trailer but that's the beauty of the MCU
everything is connected also if you're
new to my channel be sure to subscribe
I'm about to start a massive giveaway
this week so there are a few scenes in
this trailer that are just so important
to this movie but not just this movie's
important to the whole entire future of
the MCU the beginning of the trailer
acknowledges that yes Ironman did really
die an Avengers endgame however he died
saving everybody else he saved the whole
entire universe so it seems like all
over the world people have built shrines
and dedications to Ironman so the
beginning of this trailer is Peter
Parker talking to happy Hogan about how
much he misses Tony Stark but happy is
setting up spider-man to be the next
Iron Man and as you can see Peter still
obviously has his iron spider suit and
the next few scenes also set him up to
be the new Iron Man in the MCU as well
we can see that Nick Fury who was most
likely the head of shield now is trying
to contact Peter but this is called
Spider Man far from home and Peter is
just trying to go on vacation but of
course you cannot outrun Nick Fury and
then while Peter is on vacation of
course Nick Fury shows up in his room
and then we have quite possibly the
biggest if not one of the biggest
moments of the MCU Peter Parker meets
Mysterio for the very first time and he
finds out that he's not from his earth
Nick Fury explains that the snap
actually tore a hole in their dimension
and now the MCU has their very first
multiverse this opens up the MCU to so
many possibilities so many different
characters so many different story arcs
there is now more than one earth and
more than one different reality and this
is what the ancient one warned a Bruce
Banner about in Avengers endgame
she said that taking the stones from her
reality would create an alternate
timeline and yes Captain America did
return all of the stones to the point
time where they took them but events did
get altered such as Loki escaping with
the space stone this opened up an
entirely different universe one where
Loki is alive and not to mention the
universe of 2014 there is no longer a
Thanos in 2014 there's also not a Kimora
or Nebula so imagine a reality where
Thanos does not exist there are probably
a ton of characters that could exist in
that universe now because Thanos never
killed them and now we can have multiple
heroes
there could be two spider-man there
could be two hot guys there could be two
Nick Fury's this is just huge and opens
up the MCU to so many possibilities like
for starters it seems like Mysterio
Quentin Beck is actually a good guy in
this movie at least that's what they're
making him out to be now of course in
the comics he acts like he's a good guy
but is actually a bad guy and that is
most likely what is happening here
however since we now have a multiverse
that may not be the case the Mysterio
that came from the other reality of
Earth could be good like I said there's
just so many possibilities now so Peter
obviously tries to get out of being the
new Iron Man and working for shield
he asked about Thor he asked about
Captain Marvel but they're both
unavailable and Nick Fury basically is
telling him look you're not getting out
of this you've been to space you're an
Avenger so from then on out he starts to
work with Mysterio to take down the
elementals but we see a different
dynamic with Peter Parker and Mysterio
in this new trailer it seems like
Mysterio is kind of becoming somewhat of
a father figure to Peter Peter actually
probably sees him more as the cool uncle
Tony Stark was the father figure he was
really hard on him and now we have
Mysterio who was kind of like the cool
uncle we can hear him kind of comforting
Peter and he asked what do you want and
Peter says I just want to go back on
vacation and tell the girl that I like
how I feel about her but it goes a
little bit differently than how he
expected it to go instead of telling her
how he feels she tells him that she
knows he's spider-man this is something
that happens a lot both in the
spider-man movies and in the comics MJ
usually always figures out that Peter
Parker is spider-man so it seems like
they're going down the same route we
hear Mysterio talking to spider-man
again and he says you're right you may
not be ready but saving the world
requires sacrifice this is definitely a
reference to Iron Man Iron Man died
saving the world sacrificing himself and
then he says sometimes people die
just shows that spider-man is really
going to be mourning the loss of Tony
Stark in this movie which is obviously
expected it's going to be something huge
that Peter Parker has to get over not
only in this movie but also in the
future he already lost his Uncle Ben and
now he lost Tony Stark and then we have
a classic superhero conflict the
superhero is afraid of his friends
getting hurt due to him and judging by
the last scene that we saw of this
trailer it seems like notches MJ but
most of his friends are going to figure
out that he's spider-man by the end of
the movie it seems like he's definitely
going to be getting a lot more tech
during this movie including the stealth
suit which we get a great look at in
this trailer we also get an even better
look at Mysterio and his fishbowl helmet
he says that this is his job so maybe in
the alternate universe that he comes
from he actually is a superhero and his
job is to take down these elementals
which we also get a better look at as
well again anything is really possible
now that there is a multiverse in the
MCU the comics main universe is the
earth-616 universe which is most likely
the MCS main universe as well so again
that's really the main thing to take
away from this trailer it's a huge
moment for the MCU going forward this
movie is technically the last movie of
phase 3 but it is opening up the future
of the MCU to so many different
possibilities as far as characters and
stories are concerned so it's official
the snap tore a hole in the dimension of
the earth that we know in the MCU and
there are now multiverses it seems like
we're definitely going to learn a lot
more about this in spider-man far from
home and the post-credits scene for the
movie will probably set something up as
well and it seems like spider-man is in
training to become the new Iron Man so
this looks like it's going to be just an
amazing movie let me know what you think
about this do you think that Quentin
Beck Mysterio is actually going to be a
good guy in this movie because of the
multiverse or do you think that it
doesn't really change anything and he is
still the villain of this movie and he's
just trying to trick spider-man until he
can betray him let me know what you
think in the comments down below and
also be sure to tell me what you think
about the MCU officially having a
multiverse again this is huge going
forward in the MCU and has been planned
for a while now this opens it up to do a
vendor secret war and Avengers battle
world eventually down the line so again
let me know what you think let me know
how excited you are to finally see
spider-man far from home and about the
future of the end
see you be sure to subscribe so you can
enter my future giveaway and stay up to
date on everything relating to Marvel as
always thank you all so much for
watching
woof woof you said it'd cost you
everything while crying like a baby